I just always think about
what she'd be like if she
had a chance to grow up.
I miss her so much.
The Zodiac.
The classic unsolved
American crime.
"This is the Zodiac speaking.”
It's America's most
famous cold case.
Thomas Horan interview.
Take one.
Nobody has come close to
cracking this for over 50 years.
I believed all the murders
were committed by one person.
That doesn't make any sense.
The ballistics don't match.
The fingerprints don’t match.
The witness descriptions
and survivor descriptions
of the killer don’t match.
This is the first time 32 letters
have ever been analyzed...
with artificial intelligence.
I've never talked about it.
I just assumed he might
come for me.
I'd been arrested
as the Zodiac.
Did you kill Darlene?
What if there is
no Zodiac killer?